it's hard to believe it's been a full
100 days since I began my journey no my
mission into the Beating Heart of the
SCP Foundation I start this Stone wrist
detection my safety and even my own life
for this cause and I'm sure that makes
you wonder why on Earth I'd be foolhardy
enough to put so much on the line well
my reason is the best no the only reason
that matters for the sake of art I
decided early on that recording my
findings was essential both for
posterity and so that the art world may
know just how dedicated I've been in my
pursuit of true inspiration it all
started over three months ago that was
when I first managed to embed myself in
the SCP Foundation naturally I never
would have jumped at the idea of having
to fraternize with the likes of the
chaos Insurgency their methods are far
too brutal their organizations seeped in
violence that trivializes my own pursuit
of a deeper meaning but even I have to
admit the insurgency's methodology can
yield results they range for a
convenient accident to befall a lower
level researcher after they returned
home from site 19 the SCP foundation's
largest and most infamous facility home
to many of their equally Infamous
anomalies thanks to a falsified identity
and phony transfer order from the
Insurgency I was able to slip into
site-19 undetected so that I could begin
my search the subterfuge was at first
easy to maintain I looked apart
obviously a lab coat and a name badge so
versatile and yet completely unassuming
I was visible and still imperceptible to
the rest of the foundation's personnel
as far as they knew I was just the
latest transfer to site 19 as I spent
the day getting my bearings not one of
them could have possibly known my true
intention my goal was simple and twofold
first and foremost I had long felt I
deserve to be accepted as a member of
the Art Collective known as awcy or or
are we cool yet since the 19th century
they have been championing the creation
and exhibition of anomalous artwork
truly pushing the boundaries of what can
be considered artistic expression
despite the foundation's attempts to
censor AWC wise Transcendent ah I had
admired their mission statement from
afar for a number of years and strive to
achieve much the same in my own artwork
however none of my previous pieces quite
meant the collective's anomalous
pedigree I know a way to change that
though blending in at site 19 proved to
be fairly simple as long as you stride
around with purpose few will question
what you're doing with my head in a
notebook or a look of conviction on my
face I could freely make my way around
the facility but why you might wonder
what was the actual intention behind my
undercover Mission well that answer lies
in the second half of my goal
recognition not just notoriety and
acceptance into the ranks of awcy but
Fame throughout the anomalous art world
and all the perks that could come with
of course the main hurdle to overcome
was that I needed to create a piece of
art that was anomalous in its nature and
so rather than wait for inspiration and
materials to fall into my lap I chose to
instead seek out what I needed the
anomalies on offer at site 19 were
abundant and knowing where to start was
tricky I made the decision while still
getting accustomed to my new
surroundings that I would start wherever
I felt the most drawn to before the end
of my first week in site 19 I felt the
first poll of an anomaly and uncovered
it in the most unlikely of places during
my day most of the SCP Foundation living
quarters are empty meaning I could sneak
around there undetected it was in the
personal bathroom of One Foundation
doctor but I found
scp-063 to the untrained eye the anomaly
appears to be an ordinary toothbrush
save for the wording stenciled into the
pale blue plastic the world's best
toothbrush of course examining it closer
I learned of its ability to cleave
through inorganic matter like a hot
knife through butter it was quite the
shock slicing the porcelain of the
bathroom sink by accident that would
have led to my detection had I not left
soon after but I reflected on the
toothbrush or toothbrush and what it
could possibly represent perhaps an
acknowledgment of rituals and their
importance to human health yet at the
same time being sharp enough to cut
anything not organic anything not human
maybe a cp063 was meant to symbolize the
possible dangers of Habitual behaviors
the next day I was able to Bear witness
to an anomalous piece I had only ever
heard rumors of for a time I thought it
to have been the reason for AWC wise
founding after all its nickname was
derived from a particular traditional
art form
SCP-173 the sculpture as those at the
foundation call it I was able to insert
myself into a group of two other
personnel a researcher and security
officer the former was entering the
container housing SCP-173 to run tests
the latter protecting her naturally I
overheard them looking for a third and
offered my assistance even if all I had
to do was watch the sculpture intently I
wasn't even allowed to Blink without
getting someone else to cover for me
while I did I adored it the messy
structure of concrete and rebar to fight
all Notions of what many believed art
should be it wasn't beautiful or
pristine it dared to be ugly and yet it
demanded to be seen to be looked at and
perceived or else it would break my neck
and claim my life it was everything I'd
hoped pure art personified it was as I
neared the end of my first week in site
19 that I discovered my next anomalous
art piece hidden away in a storage
locker
scp-010 the colors of control these were
a collection of cast iron colors that
according to their file could be used to
control the actions and movements of a
person wearing one via a remote control
these Scholars fascinated me they were
to my interpretation tools to control
yet simultaneously a rejection of the
very rules that control human beings
someone wearing an scp-010 color could
potentially have their entire bodily
shape reconfigured by the person
wielding the remote that alone the fact
that these objects could be used to defy
the physical laws that dictate the forms
we exist in was a meta comment rejecting
the laws of society in order for free
expression expression only achieved by
Art it all made me appreciate awcy's
dedication to anomalous artworks yet I
was still determined to be welcomed into
their Collective my first week hiding
with Insight 19 concluded with a visit
to scp-107 held on a pedestal in an
otherwise empty room was an empty
hollowed-out turtle shell now I for one
don't respect geologists art historians
are another matter however I would
rather focus on translating The Human
Experience into my art than waste mental
energy on events or objects from
hundreds and thousands of years ago but
this total show might be the exception
apparently any liquid placed within the
shell will be absorbed only to rain down
from the clouds above there's something
quite honest about scp-107 interpret
through the mind of an artist such as
myself it appears to be a reminder of
the natural world's cyclical process the
liquid within it becomes rain which
falls and feeds the plants the plant
life in turn provides food in shelter
for animals humans too and so on on and
on the circle of life repeats as so
embodied by the hollow shell of an
ancient proud Turtle I began my second
week of subterfuge with a scare a close
call that I may have been discovered one
of the foundation's doctors had
complained that his sink had been sliced
in two in spite of my best efforts to
cover my tracks it seemed that using his
denture glue to repair the damage
scp-063 had done didn't quite have the
effect I had intended nevertheless the
reaction by the foundation seemed to
imply that sort of thing happened all
the time an announcement was made
reminding all researchers to not toy
with the world's best toothbrush despite
how fun it was to slice things up with
although they requested the culprit come
forward I decided to divert the
foundation's suspicions away from me
hinting to a security officer I had seen
Dr Alto cleft leaving the private
bathroom where I had accidentally broken
the sink they seemed to believe he had
been capable of causing the damage
almost being discovered meant I had to
reassess my objective over the following
few days I tried to sink into life among
the foundation's researchers playing the
role of a helpful member of personnel so
as not to attract any further suspicions
and so I was mostly concerned with the
general day-to-day tending to anomalies
most of them are I encountered during
this time were living creatures which
were of little interest to me although
one by the designation of scp-049
sporting the rather aesthetically
striking appearance of a plague doctor
complete with dark robes and a baked
mask at first I thought him to be a
quite in amicable intelligent fellow
that is until I had a moment alone with
him to ask his opinions on Art the
plague doctor claimed it was of literal
importance when compared to curing the
pestilence naturally I took that to be a
personal insult requesting to the
research head that I'd be transferred
away from an anomaly that was obviously
not as intelligent as I first thought
two and a half weeks had passed and I
had still remained undetected by the
foundation however I had been forced to
reassess my nation awcy were highly
likely to accept me into their group if
I had nothing to show for my efforts I
need to diver some materials I could use
to create an anomalous art piece or
preferably something I could claim as my
own it wasn't as if the upper echelons
of awcy possess their own detailed files
on every anomaly at site 19. they would
have no idea of something I plucked from
containment was an existing SCP or as
staff is still an original piece so I
set about finding something I could be
my magnum opus my breakthrough into the
anomalous art community my key to the
fame fortune and artistic Acclaim I so
obviously deserved you may call it
plagiarism using another anomaly as my
own piece but nobody technically owns
the objects and entities at site 19.
even the foundation themselves are more
so jailers and curators than creators I
however am a Visionary I just needed
something to prove it my search took me
far and wide all over the width and
breadth of sight 19. by the time my
first whole month had passed I'd begun
to walk the corridors and pass by its
containment Chambers just like any other
researcher although not one who I had
interacted with had any clue they were
in the presence of a man who would
reshape the anomalous art World there
was an SCP transferred from another
facility that I witnessed during that
time according to the foundations files
scp-066 had previously been a ball of
braided yarn and ribbon but had since
become an amorphous bowl of meat with
functioning eyes what struck me most
about scp-066 was the question it asked
since transforming are you Eric at first
I thought I'm not Eric but the longer I
pondered it I began to wonder allowing
my perception to be challenged that is
what art does after all perhaps much
like in The Marshall Mathers sense that
we are all Stan all of us may well be
Eric too I can recall another incident
encountering some
scp-131s creatures known as the iPods
which one almost tripped me up their
brightly colored teardrop shaped bodies
were certainly striking a rather
abstract modernist biomechanical design
but it was their eyes that I found
myself ruminating on
scp-131 instances had a single
unblinking eye giving a constant gaze
without faltering I likened it much to
the uncritical unthinking eyes of
certain audiences who in the past had
stared at my artwork and had nothing
interesting to say about it in other
events my attempts to avoid detection
may have proven a little detrimental Dr
Cliff corn on me a little perturbed that
I had implicated him in the sink slicing
incident he at one point seemed to imply
a desire to inflict far Wars damage with
a ukulele of all things although I'm
sure he was just joking at least I hope
so the whole interaction reminded me of
the urgency of my mission I still needed
my anomalous Masterpiece and would need
to have an escape plan in place once I
found it during my next stint of time
hidden among the ranks of the foundation
I tried to broaden my own interpretation
of what awcy would consider to be art
nothing in their admittedly vaguely
defined rules stated my anomalous art
piece couldn't be created from a more
modern medium never mind paintings that
can depict a person's death or a
sculpture that moves whenever unobserved
what about something like photography I
thought to myself however it was around
this time that my hopes for such a peace
were seemingly answered in the form of
scp-105 or Iris Thompson as she
introduced herself Iris had a rather
unique relationship with the Art of
Photography she possessed an ability to
alter images taken on a specific
Polaroid Express camera from 1982. in
the hands of scp-105 the photographs
would come to life like slices of
real-time Frozen one moment then moving
the second she held them she could even
alter these images reaching into the
Polaroid to move or retrieve objects it
instilled an idea in me perhaps taking a
Polaroid of My Chosen anomalous art
would be enough that is until I realized
the photographs were only in
interactable to Iris and breaking her
out of containment was a waste of my
skills as an artist part way into my
third month hiding out in site 19 part
of me began to wonder if the
foundation's security forces were as
formidable as I'd been led to believe it
seemed I barely even needed to hide my
mission to join awcy for that I had
spent so much time in their facility
undetected it was on my 68th day that I
decided to reflect on some of the
potential anomalous pieces I had
encountered so far frustratingly so I
was still yet to discover any that would
wipe the smug rins off of the awcy
members only to replace them with looks
of awe something in sight 19 would
guarantee my spot among the anomalous
Art Collective I was certain of it I
just had to find it a potential
candidate presented itself one that
might have even allowed me to get back
at awcy for denying my entry for so long
I was shown as CP 3037 a miniature model
that picked in the city of dubranovic in
Croatia I was watching it and pondering
the meaning behind the sculpture
thinking about why it was made to
specifically look like dubra novik of
all places maybe I pondered it was meant
to be a commentary or condemnation of
urbanization given the city's walls
keeping its residents contained confined
much like how we as humans have become
trapped by our Urban settings finding
comfort in being confined there however
it was while I was examining
scp-3037 that I apparently suffered
something of an incident from the moment
I touched it I spoke in only Servo
Croatian believing myself to actually be
the city of dubranovic I awoke a short
while later and was informed by another
researcher that I had been administered
with an extremely high dose of amnestics
to negate the effects of scp-30337
although later that night I recalled
having a dream about some delicious
black risotto with Squid Ink sauce the
research heads ordered security officers
to gather everywhere one in the mess
hall the foundation was seemingly aware
that they had an imposter a charlatan in
their midst pretending to be a member of
personnel I made sure my facial
expression did not betray that I was the
one they sought not one of these
Philistines could appreciate my goal of
infiltrating site 19. not one had the
slightest clue how revolutionary my
actions would be for the art World
however although staying Vigilant I
became increasingly aware time might not
be on my side much longer after
overhearing a conversation about
something known as scp-035 I began
conducting my own secretive Research
into what it was I discovered
information on the so-called possessive
mask within the foundation's archives
immediately my heart skipped a beat the
porcelain mass that shifted from an
exaggerated comedic grin to a wide frown
it would have made for a perfect art
piece to present to awcy much to my
annoyance
scp-035 was announced at site 19 however
over the next few days I petitioned to
have the possessive mask transferred to
the facilities so that I could claim it
my greatest anomalous art piece stayed
Out Of Reach though I was informed by
senior research staff that the mass
posed a potential danger anyone nearby
was compelled to wear it and would thus
be taken over by its influence
additionally questions started to be
raised as to why I was requesting this
transfer in the first place I was
starting to grow concern that my cover
had been blown by now it very much
seemed that my time was running out and
although it shames me to admit it to say
I handled that notion with Grace and
professionality well that would be a lie
suddenly I found it the perfect
anomalous art piece while rummaging
around the foundation's files I located
one about something known as
scp-1379 as I read more I realized it
would secure my spot within awcy and
forever grant me the recognition I
deserved even better it was a painting
such a classical art medium they'd never
be able to fuse me as I looked at it
directly for the first time I knew I had
found my masterpiece
scp-1379 depicted a clown and two
children on the canvas but the subject
of the painting would hardly matter to
awcy they only cared that the artwork
was anomalous and
scp-1379 certainly was this painting
would allow me to exact revenge on the
awcy members who'd failed to recognize
my artistic genius for so long anyone
that made a critical remark on
scp-1379 which those awcy snobs were
bound to do when they saw it would first
experience intense pain after 20 minutes
of shot severe Agony the sensations
would subside but that would only be the
start of it everyone at the AWC why that
dared to criticize my magnum opus my
scp-1379 would rapidly lose their
ability to imagine any of their
creativity that allowed them to laud
their artistic superiority over me would
cease exist none of them would ever make
anomalous art again and they'd surely be
forced to finally accept that I am in
fact the greatest artist of all time
from the moment I sought I began to plan
my escape with
scp-1379 in tow a hundred days have
passed since I arrived here and when I
leave it will be with scp-1379 and this
channel I've not only chronicled how I
infiltrated the SCP Foundation but also
cataloged more about anomalous art than
anyone at awcy ever has once I've lifted
that painting from its containment
Locker my old friends at the Insurgency
have arranged for me to be extracted
from site 19 with scp-1479 finally I'll
achieve my dream of this journal
belonging to one status Stearns has been
seized by the SCP Foundation Stearns was
discovered to have infiltrated site 19
after only a handful of days however
given that he posed little threat and
never left the facility secure security
officers were instructed to monitor him
closely until he attempted to escape
aware of intelligence reports regarding
various scps noted within his journal
the foundation Dean status Stearns a
security risk after 100 days subject was
arrested attempting to escape and is to
be administered amnestics his journal
will remain at site 19 until further
notice now go and check out I survived
100 days of scp-001 when day breaks
here's what happened and I survived 100
days in scp-3008 here's what happened
for more thrilling 100-day survival
challenges